[Musik]
der wiesen-wahnsinn ist zurück
[Applaus]
genauso wie es gerade ist
17 Tage lang Krüger Schleppen der
Bierdurst ist gewaltig
t wenn man auch selber eins trinken oder
alles dreht sich wieder endlich
[Musik]
es ist Mittag im Hofbräuzelt noch sind
nicht alle der rund 10.000 Plätze belegt
mittendrin Marlene und Lisa zwei von 250
Bedienungen hier schon seit 10 Uhr sitzt
die erste Kundschaft bei ihnen im Revier
knapp 14 Kilo wiegt die sechserladung
Krüger mit immer neuen Bestellungen
absolvieren die Bedienungen ein
intensives Workout
[Musik]
soweit ich mag ist dass hier gerade im
Hofbräu einfach die ganze Welt
zusammenkommt und das alle einfach nur
Spaß haben wollen das ist natürlich sehr
anstrengend aber es macht einfach so
Spaß der ganze
Wiesen worden sind es macht einfach Spaß
genau deswegen mache ich das ja
sie halten den Laden am Laufen für den
Job im Zelt braucht es Ausdauer
Leidenschaft und starke Nerven
wir schleppen ist für Marlene nur ein
Nebenjob den Rest des Jahres arbeitet
sie als achtsamkeitstrainerin das hilft
wenn es stressig wird im Riesenzelt
mit dem Tablett oder so einfach so durch
den dschung und das funktioniert
ja bis jetzt bin ich ganz gut damit
klargekommen
[Musik]
es gibt keinerlei corona-auflagen ganz
oder gar nicht war die Parole die die
Stadt für die Wiesen ausgegeben hat
wer da ist nimmt das Risiko in Kauf
[Applaus]
am Tisch nebenan hat die trinkseligkeit
zu einer Rangelei geführt die haben die
Securitys gerade schon aufgelöst
eigentlich
Menschen mitgekriegt
[Musik]
einer genau
en geholt und
das und ist jetzt alles geklärt
[Applaus]
haben aber ich
hole das noch mal
die Streithähne haben Bier und jede
Menge heimlich mitgebrachten Schnaps
getrunken und sind allein mit Appellen
an die Vernunft nicht mehr zu
beschwichtigen
wichtig ist nur dass nicht noch mehr
Gäste reingezogen werden wir angefangen
hat egal
für die aggressiven Kontrahenten ist der
zeltbesuch für heute zu Ende
wenn man mit den Leuten spricht wenn man
die Leute im Gespräch kurz ein bisschen
kennenlernen dann geht es eigentlich in
den meisten Fällen und das ist
eigentlich das schöne an diesem Job man
muss als Sicherheitsmitarbeiter nicht
nur immer zupacken nicht nur schlagen
sondern man kann auch sehr viel durch
Reden und Kommunikation lösen
15 Uhr standardeinsatz für die
Sicherheitsgruppe
Fabian und sein Team Räumen mehrere
Blöcke im Mittelschiff ab 16 Uhr sind
all diese Tische ausgebucht doch die
wenigsten wollen freiwillig gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir müssen jetzt leider Aufstehen das
dürfte mitnehmen
einfach mitnehmen
die Gäste müssen nur den Tisch verlassen
nicht das Zelt ihr Bier können Sie auch
im Stehen fertig Trinken
für Fabian ist das die zehnte Wiesen als
Sicherheitsmann eigentlich ist der
Lehrer und hier einmal im Jahr
Einsatzleiter dafür hat er sich extra
zwei Wochen freistellen lassen
gerade mal 10 Minuten brauchen sie fürs
räumen damit in Ruhe geputzt werden kann
für die nächsten Gäste
[Musik]
wir starten
sei dir ganz laut dann sind wir ganz
schnell roten Sicherheitsstand Tanja
Kaiser Grünberg in ihrem Element sie ist
jetzt für die Stimmung zuständig
hallöchen
du hörst die Leute schon und dass er
auch kommen und da sind und es ist man
kriegt Gänsehaut das ist schon ist schon
was besonderes
[Musik]
doch plötzlich kommt Stress auf
kannst du mal bitte vorkommen
und das mitten im laufenden Betrieb
was ist jetzt los und hole ich mein Mann
aber das war
kurze Störung ging er wieder an war
alles okay Gott sei Dank Pferd wieder
tanja ist Teil einer Schaustelle
Dynastie die Familie Kaiser seit
Generationen auf den Volksfesten des
Landes zu Hause doch bei aller Erfahrung
die Anspannung war diesmal groß
klappt alles kommen jetzt Leute kommen
nicht hast du genug Personal ist ja
momentan überall ein großes Problem ne
jetzt läuft alles
jeder Fahrgast zählt
wie Leute
das Publikum anlocken darum geht es auch
wenig Kaiser
er ist Tanjas Neffe
immer wieder Action boah ja wohl ja und
jetzt hier power
Po yeah Winni hat seit 2018 einen Platz
auf dem Oktoberfest für ihn das
Highlight des Jahres doch dieses Jahr
sitzt das Geld bei vielen
wiesenbesuchern nicht mehr so locker wie
früher
die hohen Energiepreise sie machen auch
ihm zu schaffen denn sein Karussell
braucht viel Strom
natürlich trifft uns alle das ist ja
ganz klar vom kleinsten Haushalt bist du
größten Firma so aber da müssen wir
jetzt alle zusammenhalten und durch ne
es ist natürlich schwer ist natürlich
ganz klar aber ja dran drehen können wir
selber nicht ne das müssen wir natürlich
warten bis sich was ändern
die Welt steht Kopf diese Clique hat
lange darauf gewartet sich wieder
richtig austoben zu können
ja ehrlich
Laura und Alina sind Schwestern aus
Gauting bei München mit sechs
Freundinnen und Freunden sind sie auf
dem Festgelände unterwegs
[Applaus]
auf den Boden und in der Luft endlich
wieder Oktoberfest
alina ist Anfang des Jahres 18 geworden
zwei Jahre lang hat sie auf die Wiesen
hingefiebert
vor allem vor zwei Jahren da wurde ich
ja im Januar 16 und dann wäre so die
Wiesen gekommen und das erste mal 16 man
darf das erste Mal ins Zelt und da wäre
es total gewesen zu gehen aber da kann
man Corona und ja jetzt bin ich 18 und
jetzt erstmal so richtig auf die Wiesen
also so mit den Zelt gehen wir trinken
feiern ja darf ich richtig Lust
es sind viele dabei für die ist das
erste Mal als Erwachsene im Festzelt ist
ohne Eltern und ohne Verbote
[Applaus]
[Musik]
laura ist zwei Jahre älter als ihre
Schwester sie war 2019 zum ersten Mal in
Zelt feiern und merkt jetzt wie teuer
alles geworden ist
so kommt das war vor drei Jahren noch 12
Euro also das weiß ich noch ganz genau
deswegen ja aber man zahlt halt
irgendwie trotzdem weil es halt
Tradition ist
anstoßen und genießen solange das
Portemonnaie halt mitmacht mehr als 600
Euro wird sie der Abend am Ende kosten
das ist ihnen jeden Cent wert die
Stimmung ist richtig richtig gut wir
haben uns mittlerweile die zweite
Beziehung ist manche auch die dritte
Maske gestellt und die Stimmung wird
immer besser
kommen wo wir einfach mal jetzt
aufstehen können
was es ankommt und die kommt dann auch
achten und sie spielen das Lied gerade
also sehr gut die Liebe werden
angestimmt jeder steigt ein das ist
perfekt das ist halt Wiesen das sind
Traum
dieser Abend für die acht ist es die
beste Party seit langer Zeit
keine Pause gewesen also jetzt wo man
hier ist also es wäre so als wäre
letztes Jahr das letzte Mal diesen
gewesen also eigentlich fast keine
Unterschiede ist
viele aus der Clique kennen sich schon
seit der Kindheit jetzt lassen sie es
gemeinsam krachen
wieder mit so vielen Menschen zusammen
zu sein und sich keine Sorgen
und so alle auf einem Haufen es ist echt
toll
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das kosten sie heute aus bis das
Licht ausgeht
[Musik]
feiern macht hungrig das Oktoberfest ist
Gastronomie im XXL-Format 2019 wurden
allein
435.000 brathemdel verkauft
an die Schönheit von der
käferwiesenschänke hat 67 Köche in der
Mannschaft es ist eine Materialschlacht
dass die zwei Jahre Pause
dort drehen also wir reden jetzt von 18
Tonnen am Tag was dann essen sie bewegen
es ist eine Kunst im Gewimmel nicht den
Überblick zu verlieren
auch deswegen ist das Oktoberfest nichts
für gastro-neulinge an der Essensausgabe
geht es schon mal raus zu
ein paar Schritte weiter im Weinzelt
legen Sie ab 17 Uhr brotzeitbrettel im
Akkord
[Musik]
Wurst oder Blutwurst dann haben wir dann
noch schöne Lampen
fast jeder Tisch im Zelt startet mit so
einem appetizerwerk in den Abend der
Preis für vier Personen
108 Euro
[Musik]
20.000 brotzeitportionen sollen es im
Laufe der Wiesen werden dann haben die
Gäste schon mal was zum essen wenn sie
kommen und dann kriegen sie später die
Hauptgänge und die Desserts
die Kunden hier gelten als ebenso
anspruchsvoll wie großzügig
mit kleinen Einschränkungen
[Applaus]
gerade hat jemand eine 6 Liter Flasche
Champagner bestellt
die 1950 Euro sind im edlen Spender dann
aber wohl doch zu viel im letzten Moment
bestellt er um und seine Gäste schlürfen
stattdessen nur Rosé für 560 Euro
die Krüge hoch heißt es auch wenn kein
Bier drin ist
[Musik]
großer Rummel auf der Münchner
Theresienwiese auch dieses Jahr werden
es wieder ein paar Millionen Besucher
sein
im Hofbräu zählt pendelt Lisa zwischen
der Küche und ihrem Revier hin und her
durchkämpfen und balancieren mit Händel
und Kartoffelsalat es ist ein
Hindernislauf durch die Menge
irgendwie durch es geht immer man muss
halt die Leute ein bisschen zur
Seite ja
später am Abend der Alkoholpegel steigt
mehr Arbeit für die Securitys
ein Funkspruch aufs Ohr von Fabian und
Kollege Hakan die Sicherheitskräfte
hinten im Zelt brauchen Verstärkung
zwei festzeltgäste sind offenbar
aneinander geraten Kollegen haben sie
getrennt was genau passiert ist und wie
es für die beiden weitergeht soll
draußen geklärt werden
vor dem Zelt stellt sich heraus einer
der beiden ist gestern schon auffällig
geworden sicher mal ja
wir sind
und schnell zu handeln
und fixiert und jetzt versuchen wir die
Sache ein bisschen zu klären wir haben
auch gleich die Polizei gerufen weil
doch die Situation etwas eskaliert sind
die Polizei braucht es am Ende dann doch
nicht beide Gäste beruhigen sich wieder
rein dürfen sie aber nicht stattdessen
Hausverbot für is Finish okay
und die beiden bleiben nicht die
einzigen für die die Party schneller
wieder vorbei ist als sie dachten
auch dieser junge Mann fliegt raus
nachdem sich die Bedienungen mehrfach
über ihn beschwert haben
[Gelächter]
es kann sehr gefährlich werden ich meine
die glasflüge sind sehr schwer wenn die
Leute betrunken sind dann machen die
Dinge die machen die sonst nicht genau
noch ein letzter Song ein letztes Mal
Party
[Musik]
doch irgendwann ist auch auf dem größten
Volksfest der Welt Schicht hier im
Hofbräu Zelt ist das Punkt halb elf so
weit die Gäste müssen raus Tische und
Bänke säubern die Bedienungen selbst
das gehört auch dazu ja das ist nicht so
schön
aber einmal hat keiner irgendwie unter
den Tisch irgendwas ja
draußen noch einmal volle Konzentration
für die Securities viele Gäste versuchen
ihren Maßkrug als Andenken mitzunehmen
mehr als 7000 prowesensaison schaffen
das auch erlaubt ist es natürlich nicht
ansonsten gilt schnell noch austrinken
[Musik]
dann heißt es auch für diesen Besucher
Abschied zumindest für heute
während die einen nach Hause gehen geht
die Arbeit für die anderen erst los kurz
nach Mitternacht
ein Tankwagen rollt aufs Festgelände
Markus scheidhammer und sein Team
bringen Biernachschub fürs Hofbräuzelt
wie jede Nacht wenn sie mit ihrer Arbeit
fertig sind lagern dort wieder 78.000
Mass Bier
das Team ist eingespielt jeder Handgriff
sitzt über eine Art Feuerwehrschlauch
wird das Bier vom Tankwagen in die
Schenke gepumpt mit hohem Druck es kommt
so kalt an dass es bis in den Krug
hinein nicht mehr gekühlt werden muss so
läuft
wir haben jetzt hier Temperatur von vier
Grad am Tankwagen also Festbier kriegen
wir in der Regel so mit drei vier Grad
in der Brauerei und die Tankwagen sind
mit 100 mm isoliert also das kann da
oder die die Biertanks auch im Lager das
steht da tagelang und nimmt vielleicht
einen halben Grad pro Tag zu
nach und nach fahren Markus und sein
Team alle vier befüllstationen des Zelts
an Zeit haben sie dafür bis 9 Uhr
morgens spätestens dann müssen sie
runter sein vom Festgelände
die Bavaria die Schutzpatronin der
Bayern ist rund um die Uhr da am Rande
des festgeländers
8 Uhr Theresia Helgert räumt ihren stand
ein die 77-Jährige Rentnerin darf als
brotfrau auf dem Oktoberfest verkaufen
weil sie bedürftig ist
sie hat als Kellnerin gearbeitet mein
Kind großgezogen die kleine Rente reicht
nicht für große Sprünge
ja ja positiv
doch zunächst muss sie Geld mitbringen
um welches zu verdienen mehr als 200
Euro Pacht verlangt die Stadt für diesen
kleinen Standplatz im Biergarten des
Schützenfest Zeltes und die Ware ist
auch teurer geworden
der Verkaufspreis für die große Breze
ist stattlich und dennoch günstiger als
im Zelt
käsestanger Käse Speck vier
Salat
zu ja es wird immer schlechter
dabei war es einst ein durchaus
lukratives Geschäft
es regnet der Brezen Verkauf stagniert
mehr aufs Geld das ist heute alles
teurer geworden Feuer spielt heute
wieder hallo hier grüße Sie eine brezi
so in die Hand dann endlich wieder
Umsatz der Appetit auf das bayerische
Grundnahrungsmittel kehrt zurück
ins gesundheitlich passt mache ich
nächstes Jahr wieder
50 Brezen und mehr verkauft sie an guten
Tagen an schlechten sind es auch mal nur
fünf ob sich das am Ende für sie rechnet
nebenan im Wohnwagenpark der
Schausteller beginnt der Tag heute
gemütlich
spätes Frühstück bei Tanja Kaiser
Grünberg und Ihrer Familie ein Moment
der Ruhe
kommt mit seinem Sohn zu Besuch
guck mal was frühstücken
[Applaus]
unter den Schaustellern gibt es an
diesen ersten wiesentagen nur ein Thema
leicht eklig gestern das Wetter
vorher war es zu heiß jetzt ist zu kalt
aber man muss trotzdem dankbar sein dass
die Wiesen stattfindet stattfinden darf
für die Kaisers ist das Oktoberfest
immer auch ein Familientreffen neben
Tanjas Neffen haben auch ihre Eltern
hier ein Fahrgeschäft außerdem noch ein
Bruder und ein Cousin ihre Vorfahren
waren Gaukler dann Zirkusartisten später
hatten sie eine pferdereitbahn hier auf
der Wiesen mein Vater hatte
Heusch Schnupfen Allergie der war auch
Pferde Liebhaber aber mit Heu und und
daraufhin sind wir dann in die
fahrgeschäftsbranche gekommen
das ganze Jahr überlebt Tanja mit Mann
und Sohn im Wohnwagen auf 70
Quadratmetern dieses Jahr waren sie
schon auf 20 Volksfesten ein Leben auf
Achse
okay
du bist froh wenn du wieder mal rein
fährst und hast auch mal ein bisschen
Ruhe aber
du bist schon als reisendes Kind willst
du wieder raus und vom Platz zur Fahrt
Platz fahren und jetzt ist mal auch froh
dass man eigentlich unser altes Leben
mal wieder in Anführungsstrichen zurück
hat ne
die Arbeit ruft für die Kaisers fühlt es
sich wie ein nach Hause kommen an nach
zwei Jahren ohne Wiesen alles nur kein
Stillstand mehr und das gilt für
Schausteller und Besucher gleichermaßen
Ansturm auf ein außergewöhnliches
Fahrgeschäft das Teufelsrad es besteht
lediglich aus einer drehenden Scheibe
gewonnen hat wie es sich am längsten
halten kann
[Applaus]
wer nicht freiwillig den Abgang macht
der wird mit dem Ball von der Scheibe
geputzt
am Ende ist das Teufelsrad wieder bereit
für eine neue Runde
Chefin an der Platte ist Elisabeth
polatschi
erklären es ist ein Geschenk auf der
Wiese sein zu dürfen
das Teufelsrad gibt es seit über 100
Jahren lange war es auf Reisen seit den
80ern dreht es sich ausschließlich hier
auf dem Oktoberfest und immer geht es um
den besten Platz den genau in der Mitte
da fallen bei erwachsenen Männern auch
mal alle Hemmungen
Elisabeths Bruder Mandy dirigiert das
Geschehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
man die findet unter den Besuchern auch
immer wieder besondere Typen die er sich
herauspickt
großer Auftritt für einen der bisher nur
mit einer glitzerjacke hervorsticht hier
schaut man gerne zu ein simples analoges
Vergnügen einer ist der Hahn im Kopf die
anderen jubeln ihm zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Besucher ein Uniform sind offiziell
hier die Mission bürgernäher
sie bürgen
selten wird ein Polizeieinsatz so
gefeiert wie dieser hier
sie probieren es mit dem Seil
aber die Fliehkraft ist stärker der
gemeinsame Abflug ist auch bei den
Polizisten unausweichlich
das war wohl die angenehme Seite des
Streifendienstes nun heißt es wieder
Waffen und Schutzausrüstung anlegen
[Musik]
auf und um die Theresienwiese sind jeden
Tag 600 Beamte im Einsatz
die Polizisten die hier Dienst schieben
machen das freiwillig
wenn es muss man schon mögen hier in dem
Fall 17 Tage am Stück
auf dem Gelände hier auch mit viel auch
hier alkoholisierten Menschen zu tun zu
haben sie suchen das Gespräch versuchen
so schlichten die gehen aber genauso
wenn Sie feststellen okay hier ist jetzt
reden nicht mehr angezeigt konsequent
vor um eben hier Straftaten zu
unterbinden oder zu verhindern
die Polizei beobachtet das Treiben auf
dem Festgelände auch mit Hilfe von 54
Kameras drei Beamte der wiesenwache
sehen dadurch sofort wo die Kollegen
eingreifen müssen
auch sie sorgen für mehr Sicherheit
Streetworker eines Münchner
sozialvereins
Svenja Schürmann und ihre Kollegen
wollen besonders jungen wiesenbesuchern
helfen
entweder haben sie es vielleicht so viel
getrunken und sie sind alleine sie
suchen den Heimweg sie weinen es sind
ganz unterschiedlich und dann bieten wir
Ihnen halt die Unterstützung anstellen
uns kurz vor und wenn wir unser Angebot
annehmen wollen dann ist es gut und wenn
nicht dann ist auch okay weil bei uns
ist alles freiwillig
einer der ersten Fälle ein junger Mann
vor einem Fahrgeschäft andere
wiesengänger kümmern sich schon
der Mann ist offenbar stark
alkoholisiert reagiert kaum auf die
Streetworker
Erstversorgung mit Wärmedecke Wasser und
Traubenzucker
Wasser trinken die Sanitäter sind schon
alarmiert bis sie kommen bleiben die
Helfer vor Ort
[Musik]
besonders wichtig ist vor allem für die
Personen da zu sein einfach in den zu
reden sie immer wieder wach zu rütteln
in den Wärme zu geben dass sie nicht
alleine sind und auch wissen ist kümmert
sich jemand nimmt den Müttern super
danke schön geschützt vor Blicken wird
der Mann in Sanitätszelt gebracht
die Streetworker sind vor allem an den
Wochenenden unterwegs es geht auch darum
junge Frauen vor sexuellen Übergriffen
zu schützen hallo Entschuldigung wir
wollten wir wissen ob es für dich in
Ordnung ist
einvernehmlich oder nicht in dieser
Situation für die Streetworker schwer zu
erkennen
t und sieht ausgewichen wollten einfach
davon ihr die Zustimmung des abklären ob
dieser Kontakt für Sie in Ordnung so ist
oder nicht und haben ihr eben auch
angeboten dass wenn es nicht in Ordnung
ist wie auch mit ihr sozusagen aus der
Situation rausgehen können
diese Frau braucht keine Hilfe alles
okay
je später die Stunde desto mehr werden
Sie gebraucht etwa 50 Fälle haben Sie an
einem typischen wiesenabend
auf der wirtsbudenstraße gibt es
plötzlich drei Einsätze gleichzeitig
an verschiedenen Stellen liegen Männer
volltrunken auf dem Boden Svenja und
ihre Kollegen packen spuckbeutel aus
nicht zum letzten Mal an diesem Abend
[Musik]
die Vögel fun Band hat alles im
Repertoire was zum Mitsingen einlädt
jetzt sitzt im Weinzelt keiner mehr auf
der Bank
[Musik]
sie sind der Motor der die Party am
Laufen hält bis weit nach Mitternacht
[Musik]
das lassen sie sich nicht zweimal sagen
es ist Halbzeit auf dem größten
Volksfest der Welt der wilde
wiesenwahnsinn ist zurück und wem es
heute nicht genug war der kommt halt
morgen wieder zum Feiern fahren und
flanieren
[Musik]